really great thing about teaching is you
know sort of a cliche to say that every
class is different that is true but it's
also sort of many eras are different
right so I've been doing this long
enough to know that and soon as you can
see it only in retrospect but that there
are certain things that really anime
students right at different times in
different moments so for example
questions about the history of sexuality
like if you tell students the effeminate
in the Renaissance meant that you liked
women too much right that was the
definition it it kind of blows their
mamas right and it blows their minds and
how they think of a Shakespeare play but
it also blows their mind and how I mean
if you teach you well and how they think
about their own ways of organizing
masculinity femininity and desire and
those sorts of things it seems to me are
very keyed into other sort of issues or
or you know moments that are going on
both within the University of the whole
and more widely so for example there are
debates in the political sphere above
gay marriage students are going to be
keying into sort of debates about
crossdress Shakespeare comedies in which
two characters dressed as men marry each
other in a different way or for example
teaching a fellow right at a moment when
you know middle which is a play about
the relationship between east and west
in between the Ottoman Empire and sort
of broadly conceived Christianity and
you're teaching that at a moment as I
just did this semester where you know
you're talking about going to war again
middle east again that's going to key
students interest in a different way
than it would have trying to think of a
moment in recent history Middle Eastern
politics word and I can't but it is
going to you know animate what they say
so students really trying to understand
where is Cypress because that means
something very particular during the
Arab Spring or you know it's very um and
that kind of flex the ability which
isn't simply like let's apply next thing
that I'm teaching to your lives right
but instead of looking because i don't
like that as a pedagogical style at all
but instead this is sort of saying okay
what are what are some of the things
that are going to be animating students
interests of curiosity right and how can
that be sort of a teaching moment not
about a particular political agenda but
about issues that solidify at certain
moments of powerful public discourse you
know East represents acts or you know
whatever it is and that's again what I
mean about that sort of productive
tensions stuff right it's not like
though the east was always the east Yeah
right it's instead sort of using a
contemporary interest to then really
think critically about